una cifra de ganancias
récord llegó al presidente Joe biden a
criticar a las petroleras y pedirles que
detengan las ganancias de guerra
refiriéndose al conflicto en Ucrania
no han cumplido su compromiso de
invertir en Estados Unidos de apoyar al
pueblo estadounidense una por una las
principales compañías petroleras han
reportado ganancias récord no solo un
rendimiento justo por el trabajo duro
todas las empresas tienen derecho a eso
pero me refiero a beneficios tan altos
que es difícil de creer
además les pidió aumentar la producción
en caso de no cumplir Instagram el
congreso a imponer impuestos la idea de
bailén es mitigar los elevados precios
de la gasolina que afectan el bolsillo
de los estadounidenses a principios de
Julio pagaban unos 4,80 dólares en
promedio por un galón de gasolina normal
aunque los precios han bajado a unos
3,76 dólares de media a nivel nacional
pero la Casa Blanca afirma que deberían
ser más bajos dado el descenso de los
precios mundiales del petróleo en el
mismo periodo los gigantes mundiales de
la energía registraron enormes
beneficios trimestrales Epson móvil tuvo
ganancias de 20.000 millones de dólares
mientras Chevron de 11.200 millones
estas ganancias se deben al incremento
del precio del gas natural y de los
combustibles que inciden en el aumento
de la inflación a nivel mundial subir
los impuestos en Estados Unidos para las
grandes petroleras no tendrá un camino
fácil en el congreso menos aportas de
las legislativas de medio término donde
la buena salud de la economía ha estado
en la mirada de los electores